there's a big new push to crack down on
annoying robo calls from overseas the
Federal Communications Commission
approved new rules surrounding those
illegal calls technology makes it easy
for scammers to keep dialing to get
money and they may be using your number
to do it Kris Van Cleave is at the FCC
Kris what do these new rules do well
good morning it's a goal to at least try
to slow down the dialing for dollars but
really there are three certainties in
life now death taxes and robo calls they
just keep coming we got several we're
putting this piece together they're the
number one complaint into the FCC this
latest effort is part of a larger
government crackdown we call on our
department number this call from the
department they just keep coming in June
robo calls flooded our phones at a rate
of nearly 1,700 a second 1.8 billion
from scammers you feel so helpless
because you have no control over where
your phone numbers going foreign
scammers hijacked Beverly Figueroa his
cell number through a technique called
spoofing making it appear as if she was
calling countless potential victims
hundreds of them
called her fighting mad until she
changed her number I literally sat there
in tears in a unanimous vote yesterday
the Federal Communications Commission is
trying to help making it illegal for
foreign callers to spoof a US number
with the hope it'll prompt phone
companies to block more calls and texts
and give law enforcement new tools to go
after scammers they drive me crazy too
FCC Chairman Ajit PI they're already
breaking the law right so telling them
not to do it this way is that really
gonna stop somebody who's already
breaking the law well we are confident
that the FCC exercising the authorities
we have will be able to stop some of
these problems before they materialize
this isn't the end of robo calls by any
measure
Roger Chang from CNET the additional
enforcement powers can only help but
that said these these scammers these
robo call folks are they're smart people
then they've been able to continually
outwit and really
advance and upgrade their game a phone
scam cost Alfreda and Mike flavin more
than $80,000 a caller posing as a lawyer
with a tennessee number convinced the
couple in their late 70s their grandson
had been arrested and if they sent cash
the charges would disappear this is an
evil evil scam that preys upon the
emotional connection that grandparents
have for their grandchildren and it's
just it's absolutely horrible
Erica flavin is their daughter my mother
has all of these health issues how are
they going to manage you know their
retirement their pensions what about my
mom's medical bills this was money that
they could have used for all of that and
it's gone it's never coming back the FCC
says you don't have to answer those
calls from an unknown number if it's
important they'll leave a voicemail and
don't send money to strangers now the
agency has told phone companies they
need to adopt new technology that can
determine if a call is legitimate by the
end of the year but in the meantime
those annoying robo calls and the scams
that go with them we're gonna keep
coming in flat yeah Chris they can be
annoying for some people but for others
are some real life consequences that you
never think about my in-laws were the
target of one of their you know your
grandson has been arrested scams it's I
mean it's just almost evil what these
people do is scare the hell out of
people and take their money take their
life savings it's better I try to scare
them back when they call me yeah can you
be scary Michelle absolutely I can tell
you she can be scary